[Musique]
seule chose dont les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est clark la commode un
père d'élève clark et la une des médias
grosse info je vois pas clark
il est peut-être en train de dormir papa
lé plus gros fragment de la coved clark
vont très bientôt entrer dans notre
atmosphère
tout à fait et il ya un choix de fortes
charges si je pense que le spectacle
soit impressionnant ou est ce qu'il voit
jean sérère un des premiers morceaux va
s'écraser s'écraser un petit morceau et
ce sera dans l'océan 2
non mais regardez sa as
eh ben ça a pas explosé
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride au monde attendait il va y en
avoir encore d'autres allait bien on se
regarde newswires
deux jours ils ont dit des conneries il
y aura d'autres fragments qui vont
détruire la terre les agences spatiales
on parle d'une possible extradition
on va affronter ça ensemble auquel grand
faut juste qu'on trouve à
[Musique]
des avions militaires volver des bunkers
au groenland
c'est notre seule chance
lessard
allison
mais papa on veut y trouver le plus gros
fragment de classe va s'écraser dans
moins de vingt quatre heures je le jure
je vais conduire ma famille dans ce
bouquin
j'en suis sûr frustrant si vous entendez
ce message chercher un refuge
immédiatement qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est
ce qui se passait j'entendais ce message
girard
accroche-toi aux attentes
immédiatement chercher un refuge
immédiatement
[Musique]
j'allais
[Applaudissements]
tu sais ce que c'est un klaxon de
courtoisie jeune homme tu sûr que c'est
ce que tu as bien voulait faire non pas
du tout
avec à vous excuser lyon pourra oublier
tout ça ignore le cas
tu peux y aller ce to play
vous allez bien je suis quasiment sûr
que ce pick-up me suis un enragé de la
route compétents rap le mec
je crois pas que vous sachiez réellement
ce que c'est une mauvaise journée
mais vous allez découvrir
c'est un roger bon téléphone ça tourne
quessette leaf inclus avec thomas mis
d'accord c'est ici que commence cette
première leçon à des moments où je peux
pas faire ça
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
vous appreniez ce qu'est réellement une
mauvaise juin avec vous appreniez à dire
que vous êtes désolé vous êtes enfin
réveillé je suis bien les billets savait
devoir sortir le grand jeu
parce que vous allez on va avoir besoin
[Musique]
félicitations pour ton premier
commandement
enfin j'espérais toujours te retrouver
et vie même si je suis un millier de
kilomètres c'est ma première
j'ai un écho à mon avis c'est un foot là
vont couler fusées de détresse
commandant
les navires du convoi ont été touchés on
a une meute de loups vôtre aussi
bon
ont perdu sept bâtiments et 50 des faits
hier
qu'on est là aujourd'hui c'est
insuffisant
porter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cible a disparu commandant
mais voilà qu'arrive qu'est-ce qu'on
on va dessiner les feux de l'enfer sion
c'est toi la scientifique alors j'étudie
les schémas comportementaux de la faute
des grands et je prévois les
conséquences écologiques au plus près
c'est pas normal les baleines ne se
proches pas des bateaux il ya quelque
chose qui change la texture du bois dis
moi que tu sais ce que c'est
[Musique]
quelque chose traverse la commune
c'est quoi ce truc
[Musique]
2 un seul animal il avait des parasites
dont monsieur qu'est ce que c'est de
l'art on dirait on peut tous être
contaminé
je veux que tu ne teste tous
aux troupeaux il ne s'agira pas d'une
guerre de héros et nation ce massacre
ont les unes les autres et nous
deviendrons harris
ça va être amusant
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas me garder enfermés
alors que le monde s'embrase
monfils le monde est gouverné
par la corruption il avidité
vont intervenir certainement
nous sommes la première agence de
renseignement indépendante raffiné mais
brutaux civilisé mais impitoyable
bienvenue au club c'est très malin il
est temps de verser de l'huile sur le
feu
de la révolution est mon berger
des nuls en anglais raspoutine votre
réputation vous précède
[Musique]
réglons ce entre gentlemen après tout
ses manières
jument
pourquoi les hommes sont ils toujours
aussi brouillon
[Musique]
donnez les marques vous pouvez vous
passer de votre téléphone pour quelques
heures
et si je vous disais une histoire plutôt
besoin de héros de méchants d'aventuré
et de magie du rêve de voir dans la
vraie magie
derrière les murs de ce manoir il y a
des secrets bien cachés
quote j'ai vu un truc là-bas
[Musique]
tu ne risques rien dégoûté bien d'où
exactement un monde magique
malheureusement tout cela a disparu
notre reine nous a envoyé ici pour
sauver notre monde et empêcher son
extinction mais bien sûr une sorcière
maléfique nous à suivre tu ne vois pas
que je sais de sauver notre monde notre
mans ne vaut pas la peine d'être tournée
des magiciens des portail magique
lilikim sorcière qui est prêt à ce
sommet notre monde vous attendez quoi on
y va ou fatwa ouvrait toutes les portes
on a besoin que de quatre éléments je
lai
vrai de nouveaux mondes et
condé à l'appel
ouais tu sors un poignard à une bataille
de sorcier elle n'a pas tort on est tous
derrière toi
rufus c'est le royaume d'aline a voir
absolument
[Musique]
et
non
dans ce pays il ya plus de brodard
cachés sous les matelas accrochées au
mur
la serrure n'a pas été forcée on dirait
que c'est le même mode opératoire et les
collectionneurs ne déclarent pas leurs
pièces maîtresses exactement ils
paieraient beaucoup trop d'impôts elles
ne sont pas déclarés mais elle change de
mains c'est le comportement typique de
l'assassin froid et méthodique
tous les événements se sont déroulés
dans ce secteur que des rues qui regorge
de collectionneurs d'antiquaires de gens
riches
j'ai c'est que c'est un moment
douloureux mais il faudrait vous allez
chez votre fille et que vous me disiez
s'il manque quelque chose
est ce que quelque chose a disparu
à
j'imagine que vous savez que goya
réalisé la série des caprices en 1799
donc ses planches ont pu servir à tirer
une infinité de copies une infinité non
l'assureur injecte décorateur tout le
monde peut en avoir un ben au moins on a
une piste telle nature optimiste et bah
tu sais que je suis pas d'accord avec
tout ça si quelqu'un d'autre ce été tué
pendant qu'on est occupé à recenser les
forces que tu proposes alors j'ai
entendu ce qu'a dit le commissaire ils
étaient surpris de 6 pdb regard à au
numéro 8
comme toujours je vous demande d'être
prudents et discrets de cambrai
si on n'a pas de suspect on va pas les
inventer royal
pourquoi tu es si pressé
e
[Musique]
bienvenue à creissels zen bonjour nous
sommes nouveaux vlad et barnabas dépêche
[Musique]
dans un lieu magique crise felden abri
depuis plus de sept cents ans l'école de
magie la plus réputée de toute la
planète
entouré d'une forêt obscure vous pouvez
marcher pendant des jours vous sortirez
toujours par l'endroit où vous êtes
entré des êtres enchanté votre septième
année est une année magique c'est
l'année où vous allez accueillir votre
héritage familial
et trois amis extraordinaire je
m'appelle vlad un vampire qui supportent
pas le sens je suis fait une fée qui a
peur de voler moi c'est wolf chef un
loup garou tient une allergie aux poils
vont devoir accomplir leur plus grande
mission après de nombreuses luc viendra
le temps où le mât contrats pour des
prunes à salles d'abord puis 3 unis pour
dompter leurs faiblesses sauver le monde
magique commençait pour traverser
et le fragment de sang
[Musique]
ces enfants tranquilles
d'accord c'est pas le bon surtout pas de
panique magic kids est un peu plus haut
encore j'en ai bien peur way